Next equality,
equity,
that's worse,
right?
Equity means equality of outcome.
It means that every single organization
has 50 percent women and 50 percent men.
It doesn't matter whether the men and
women differ in their intrinsic
preferences,
which by the way they do the scientific
literature on that is completely clear.
It was established by the early
nineties.
It was established in the Scandinavian
countries where they've done most to
flatten out the socioeconomic
differential between men and women.
Didn't get rid of the differences
between men and women.
In fact,
they became exaggerated.
The biggest personality differences in
the world between men and women are in
Scandinavia,
just as the biggest differences in
interests between men and women are in
Scandinavia because when you get rid of
the sociocultural differences between
men and women,
the biological differences don't
disappear.
They maximize how else could it be,
and as I said,
the literature on that is clear and the
way that the postmodernists radicals
react to that is by criticizing the
scientific method itself on their
computers,
which only work of course,
because of the scientific method.
Actually.
Yeah,
works.
You hear the egalitarianism,
Clarion call everywhere.
Everything should be equal.
Everything should be equally
distributed.
We should strive for equity.
It's like wrong,
especially if you're a conservative,
wrong.
What we want are just hierarchies of
competence.
Not everyone's a neurosurgeon.
You know,
if your father has a brain tumor,
you probably want a hierarchy of
competence for neurosurgeons so you can
pick the one that's the best so that he
might not die.
That's what a hierarchy of competences
for.
For the postmodernist,
there's no hierarchy that isn't based on
power.
Well,
because they think the world runs on
power and that's why they're willing to
use power to get what they want because
it's the only thing they believe in,
but a valid hierarchy of competence.
It's God,
we need those things,
man.
We need the best plumbers.
We need the best contractors.
We need the best.
We knew we need the best carpenters,
we need the best lecturers.
There has to be a hierarchy of quality,
not only so that we know who the best
are and can reward them properly,
but so that we can reward them so they
keep being the best.
It's like you know,
if,
if you have a great educator,
if you have a great leader,
if you,
if you have a great thinker,
you want to reward them so they keep
thinking and they keep educating so they
can tell you something.
It's not a reward for their intrinsic
being.
It's a calculated move on your part to
suck everything out of them that's
valuable as fast as you can.
That's what a hierarchy of competence is
for.
And the idea is that hierarchies of
competence don't exist is it's so
cynical,
it's such a pathologically cynical idea
and it's actually quite untrue because
here's an interesting tidbit from the
psychological literature.
Let's say you want to determine what the
best predictors are for lifetime success
in a Western society.
Well,
what would you hope for?
How about intelligence there?
It'd be a good one.
Let's hope the smart people occupied
more positions of complexity,
right?
Because they're smarter when you want it
any other way.
Okay.
And then so and that's great.
The number one predictor of
accomplishment in western societies is
intelligence.
So that means the system works.
What's the number to predictor
conscientiousness?
Well,
what's that?
It's a trait marker for hard work,
so who called,
who gets ahead,
smart people who work hard now that
doesn't account for every bit of the
difference between people in terms of
their hierarchical structure because
hierarchies aren't perfect.
They're corrupt.
People get to the top sometimes because
there's psychopathic,
although believe me,
a hell of a lot less than you think
because a psychopath has to keep moving
from place to place because once he
reveals himself as deceitful and
untrustworthy,
he has to go find new soccer's to
fleece.
So the idea that you know,
there's no distinction between a CEO and
a psychopath.
It's like that's only made by someone
who a knows nothing about psychopaths
be,
knows nothing about ceos and c has
something fundamental against the entire
capitalist structure because it's simply
not true.
Corrupt,
sometimes greedy,
sometimes short,
shortsighted,
sometimes running companies that are
doing their best to auger themselves
into the ground and so you know it's bad
people running a dying organization,
but generally speaking,
it's not the case.
Our hierarchies of competence are
reasonably functional and not only are
they functional,
they're valuable.
We need to know who the competent people
are and we need to reward them and even
more importantly,
we need to tell young people,
hey,
there's some hierarchies of competence
out there,
like a thousand of them.
Go be a plumber man,
but be a good one.
You know,
being honest.
One B.
I had a plumber once,
you know,
it was the night,
it was the night before we were putting
drywall in our house.
We were redoing a house and he had put
in all the plastic piping,
you know,
and I was going to test the joints,
the,
they're supposed to be glued together
with his pipe glue.
Right?
And I said,
I told her I had to test the joints and
he said,
well,
you don't have to test my joints.
They never leave.
Can I thought,
yeah,
that's okay.
How about if I test them?
So I went up on the third floor and
filled the pipes with water,
capping them in the basement like you're
supposed to.
Like half an hour later I had two inches
of water in the basement.
There were 30 leaking joints.
That was the night before the drywallers
were supposed to show up so well,
so he wasn't particularly competent.
That's the point of that story,
but even more so he had put a bunch of
plastic pipe outside where the drywall
would be,
so it would have been sticking through
the wall.
So I spent a frenetic night,
you know,
sawing through plastic pipe and re
gluing joints so that my.
So that the drywallers could come in.
What's the point if you're going to be a
plumber,
man,
be a good plumber because otherwise all
you do is go out there and cause
trouble.
We don't need people to cause more
We need people to solve problems,
you know?
And so you can be a tradesman and you
can be,
you can make a lot of money as a trades
person.
It's a bloody reliable,
honorable,
a forthright,
productive way of making a living.
And there is a hell of a lot of
difference between a working man who
knows what he's doing and one who
doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics.
Right?
And you work with someone who knows what
they're doing.
It's a bloody pleasure.
They tell you what they're going to do,
they tell you how much it will cost.
They go and do it.
It works,
and you pay them perfect.
Everyone's happy,
and that's what happens when you have
genuine hierarchies of competence and so
you to.
You listen to these panderers of
egalitarianism,
a gallery,
egalitarianism and equity,
and they fail to recognize completely
that there are differences in rank
between people.
It's not such a terrible thing,
man.
Maybe he wouldn't be a great lawyer like
it's certainly possible.
Most people aren't,
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at.
There's lots of hierarchies to attempt
to climb and if you fail in one,
go try in another,
but the point is you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do?
If you don't try to aim for the top,
you know,
flap about uselessly and whine about
your life.
It's not helpful.
It will just make you miserable.
You're not reliable to anyone.
You can't help out in a crisis.
It's like,
so you tell young people,
and this is another message for
conservatives,
like,
I don't care why you're going to do,
but go out there and make something of
yourself for God's sake,
be an honest person and work and get to
the top of whatever it is that you want
to get to the top of you know,
and,
and stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a
blight.
You know,
and you can tell young people that and
they haven't been told that by anyone
now and so the young men are so hungry
for that,
that it's,
it's painful to watch.
They're so relieved when finally someone
finally comes up and says,
Hey,
you know,
you,
you get your act together,
bit discipline yourself.
See if you can learn to tell the truth,
concentrate on something for a year or
two.
You could be a bloody world beater.
They think that's possible.
Wow.
That would be,
that would be interesting.
That might make life or life worth
living.
It's like,
yeah,
it might.
So why don't you go do it now?
That's what the damn universities we're
supposed to be teaching people and
they've forgotten that.
I went to Harvard month ago,
month and a half.
He used to teach there and I talked to a
bunch of students.
You know what I told them?
It's not easy to get into Harvard,
you know,
like you're a Valedictorian if you're at
Harvard and not only are you a
Valedictorian,
you're way better than most people,
at least two other things or you don't
get in.
It's so like it's.
I don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent.
And believe me,
not everybody applies.
So it's a very selective school.
And so why am I saying that?
It's like these are high quality kids.
So I told them what I just told you.
It's like,
here you are at Harvard.
It's like get yourself educated man.
Read some books,
learn to talk,
learn to think.
Make yourself into something,
get the hell out there and make the
world that put you here.
Happy that you were put there in that
great institution,
you know?
And they came up to me afterwards and
said,
God,
I wish someone would have told us that
when we were in our first year.
It's like,
Jesus,
why didn't someone tell them that for
God's sake,
it's supposed to be the greatest
university in the world.
Is it so difficult to figure that out?
Well,
it is.
If that is what you want to have happen
in the university,
you want to make cringing milk sops who
whined about being victims while they're
going to ivy league institutions.
Jesus
pathetic.
Here's an old idea from Carl young.
I really liked this idea.
It's a rough one,
man.
It's like a psychotherapeutic scalpel.
Let's say someone's doing something to
you.
You don't understand.
It's producing nothing but misery as an
outcome.
It's like,
what the hell is your motivation?
They won't tell you.
Maybe they don't know.
So Carl [inaudible] advice was look at
the outcome and infer the motivation.
Okay?
So you produce a generation of students
privileged beyond belief in comparison
to the rest of like struggling humanity
in all of history.
You put them in Ivy League schools and
they come out thinking that they're
members of an oppressed group and
victims.
It's like,
well,
why would you?
Why would anyone?
Why would that happen?
And the answer is,
well,
that's what the people who taught them
wanted to turn them into and then you
might think,
well,
did they do that because they cared for
them?
It seems bloody unlikely to me.
You take this great raw material,
right?
I mean,
it's taken a lot of work to make an
institution like the University of
Toronto are like Harvard.
We'd been working on that for thousands
of years and you invite people in.
You thank God we selected you so
carefully because we think you can be a
world beater and then what we do is we
don't teach you how to think.
We don't teach you how to speak.
We don't get you to read great books and
we convinced you that you're a victim
and that your culture is corrupt.
So great with those people are no
friends of those institutions.
I can tell you that,
and they're even less friends of those
students,
so hierarchies are cough,
competence are desirable,
and they should be promoted.
So none of this idiot,
egalitarian equity,
it's not good for anyone.
First of all,
it's impossible.
Second,
it would be murderous to impose,
but third,
even if it succeeded,
it would fail as fast as it succeeded.
That would be how fast it would fail.
Why would you strive for anything if
there was no option to strive for?
If everything's flat and equal?
Well,
when you're starving or dying than
everyone's equal,
and believe me,
the egalitarian,
the iee Galitary and totalitarians who
dominated the 20th century knew
perfectly well how to make people equal
and they made them equal in gulag work
camps and in starvation,
and I'm sure we could attain that if we
wanted to.